[Music]
by 42 farming is taking a bit of a
different look here in the valley
a brand new vertical urban farm open
just west of the las vegas strip
and they're growing something called
micro greens tiny little vegetables
hector broccoli mejia is live near
valley view
and tropicana this morning tell me
hector please tell me you ate all your
vegetables this week
hey there cheryl i became a broccoli
today
wow you see right in front of you that
is uh that is
radish and uh it's less than a week old
so
we have all of these trays and so
instead of having acres and acres and
acres of a farm
we have this vertical farm and this is
happening here in the valley they also i
have uh they they've partnered with
non-profits to
uh supply some of these great vegetables
to local kids so we're going to take a
walk over here we're still kind of
waking up the plants so it's a process
and joining us i have to talk about that
process we have
mark ceo here at urban fresh farms all
right so what all goes into growing
these little baby vegetables
they're actually quite simple hector we
plant the seeds on a hemp mat
we water them we put them in 80 degree
uh 80 relative humidity
germination chamber and in three days
they germinate then we move them into
the grow
how packed are they with nutrients
the radish would have seven to ten times
more
nutrition than a radish how does that
happen
it's because they come from the
embryonic seed the
seed plants put all their nutrients into
their seed
and then they die right so that seed has
all the nutrients that that plant
produce its whole lifetime
that's sitting in the embryonic seed
these plants rely on that seed to grow
we don't use fertilizers we don't use
pesticides and what's
also so cool it's it's a brand new
company and it's happening here in the
valley they're working to get into
grocery stores
and right now people can stop by and uh
buy some vegetables here on site
absolutely we can
do a like a grab and go type situation
here we package in four ounce clam
shells
awesome thank you very much so we're
gonna take a walk over here we're gonna
check these out
and uh we'll have another update for you
guys in about half an hour so this is
just
one small section of a larger area here
and again we're just
trying to wake up the plants right now
reporting live hector mejia
back to you guys